police in Bangladesh have fired tear gas
and rubber bullets during the latest
anti-government protest there the
opposition blames the government for
soaring food and energy prices they want
the government to be replaced with a
caretaker Administration to ensure Fair
elections next year let's get the latest
from Dhaka with our correspondent tanvir
Chowdhury and Tanya you are with those
huge protests in the streets yesterday
and then this violence took place at a
sit-in today
thank you
yes absolutely that was one of the
biggest Gathering of the oppositions in
many years at the same time there was a
large Gathering just few kilometers away
from where the oppositions were gathered
by the ruling opposition party so
tension was already high right after the
Gathering the opposition announced that
they'll have a sit-in programs all the
intersection to the capital DACA which
connects with the rest of the country
this was not something provocative but
they say we'll have a peaceful City and
as a protest now around 11 30 local time
today what we are hearing that the
police sort of interfered and then
protested Chase back at the police after
they were attacked in the process dozens
of opposition members were injured at
least two senior leaders were badly
injured beaten up by police two of them
were detained one of them has been
released so far what we know things are
a bit calmer now now the what's
important to realize that this police
attack on the opposition was also being
coordinated by the ruling party
supporters as used as an auxiliary force
and that's quite provocative people were
expecting that to happen because the
ruling party has been threatening that
we will deal with the industry in our
own way
well prime minister Sheikh Hasina has
been in power now for what 14 years is
there actually any indication that she
might be willing to leave office ahead
of Elections next year
me
highly unlikely she is very adamant
she's counting her on her economic
success Bangladesh did have a very good
economic growth since she came to power
started slowing down after the pandemic
since 2021 and now the economy is really
suffering the food prices High inflation
is high you know energy cost is high a
lot of those people who go in this
opposition protests are actually
Ordinary People they're fed up with it
people's salary hasn't been increased at
the same time the election is on the
horizon uh the end of this year or
probably January next year so there is a
big election Mania typically here people
do not trust the ruling party to conduct
the election we are President here of
election being conducted under neutral
caretaker Administration and if you ask
in the state most people would want that
but the government said it's not in the
Constitution they got away with it and
she will stick to having an election as
per Constitution she said although
there's been a lot of international
pressure from the U.S the EU and the you
and telling the government to have a
peaceful election even day before
yesterday 14 congressmen wrote to the
U.N that there should be observer in
this election in Bangladesh and suddenly
Elite forces of Bangladesh should be
barred from taking part in the
peacekeeping operation so a lot of
pressure on the government to have a
free and neutral election and at the
same time the opposition is gaining
momentum and it wants to continue to put
the pressure on the government to have
it
election under a caretaker
Administration well certainly tense
times in Bangladesh tanvi Chowdhury in
the capital DACA for us thank you tambi